chapitre 1 l'histoire commence notre
histoire commence mercredi matin à 7
heures quand des enfants se préparent à
aller à l'école fondée là il était une
fois à willencourt 22 élèves de l'école
alain cavalier qui écrivirent leurs
romans une épopée fantastique de 170
pages à propos de deux enfants qui
découvre un mystérieux labyrinthe et se
retrouvent piégés
on voulait écrire quelque chose qui est
l imaginaire qui a été prêt n'était pas
dans la revue comme on pouvait écrire
les chapitres qu'on voulait en plus et
en plus ce qu'on pouvait le faire en
gros poste tout seul c'est bah c'était
bien c'était bien d'écrire un livre
parce que c'était collective ont voté
pour choisir les noms des cheveux le
labyrinthe fantastique est le fruit
d'une année de rédaction avec leurs
professeurs recherche d'idées
construction de l'intrigué est mise en
place du récit une heure de travail par
semaine dans la peau d'un écrivain un
projet d'écriture pédagogique mais aussi
un moyen de donner confiance aux élèves
c'était la première fois que je le
faisais professionnellement et j'ai
trouvé que le bilan est très positif à
la fois en termes de pédagogique mans en
termes de progrès en rédaction pour
l'ensemble de la classe de progrès en
lecture en termes de dons pour le livre
et de le fait pour certains d'entre eux
d'avoir démystifié cet objet là et
d'avoir un petit peu moins
d'appréhension à l'idée de d'écrire et
de lire chacun des élèves a pu recevoir
un exemplaire de leur roman et si vous
osez plonger dans le labyrinthe
fantastique des extraits sont
disponibles sur le site d'elancourt